[Music]
hi i'm claire jones i'm editor of the
financial times's trade secrets
newsletter there's been a perfect storm
of factors really
some are pandemic related some are more
longer term
most of the time we spend our income on
services we go out to the pictures to
concerts to restaurants that hasn't been
happening so much
so what's happened instead is that we're
spending more on consumer durables and
overwhelmingly those consumer durables
reach us by a container ship from abroad
and that's putting a lot of pressure on
the logistics industry
immediately what you had in the early
months of the pandemic was a complete
shutdown that involved not only places
like restaurants and concert venues but
also factories
you can't be as productive necessarily
as you were pre-pandemic when you have
covered restrictions in place
[Music]
they were operating worker shifts unless
staff would come in a lot of staff were
also off because you know they either
were sick themselves i think we've also
seen a lot of people
wanting to change careers during the
pandemic and i think that is having an
impact on supply chains too
a lot of people don't want to be truck
drivers anymore or work in warehouses
it's led to quite a profound rethink and
that has left
the industry really shorter short of
workers at times too
[Music]
the idea is that that makes your
business a lot more efficient if you're
only getting the goods exactly when you
need to use but the problem with that is
that there's no spare capacity of what
economists like to call slack in the
system
the convenience that we enjoyed and you
know still have been enjoying for a
certain extent
that might change a little bit in the
years
[Music]